what's going on is Hannibal Burres DJ
Tony true you watch a comedy karma Sato
TV we are here in Sacramento California
the capital of California yeah I'm here
in the parking lot of my hotel the BEST
WESTERN yes
look what yeah I only stay at the finest
as I do and you know the people kept
asking me I said I was gonna retire from
the restaurant review game I said I was
done but they keep bringing me back in
every time I think I'm out they pull me
back so we're gonna do a restaurant
review did we look at the top rest to
run this a Sacramento and see the
five-star places yeah yeah could go we
could go to that places am I gonna go to
the place with the best for Gua or the
best asparagus for the best lettuce in
the business I could go to those places
those places I easy to find could I go
to the place where the locals go
but I'm not doing that I'm going to the
restaurant
there's directly next to the BEST
WESTERN PLUS it's the restaurant that
inspired the jay-z album that has the
same title great album
so let's go into the jay-z restaurant
album